[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 94. i checked
i'm certain of the number it is 94. it's
even therefore don't have to see if it's
prime because it ain't
all right we got stuff going on yep we
do lots of stuff as usual um we're going
to be talking about adulthood and
aspects of adulthood and ways to uh ways
to mature into adulthood
uh today but first just some some
housekeeping stuff if you're watching on
youtube consider switching over to
odyssey that's where the chat is enabled
for those of you watching live
you can submit questions for the q a
that will follow this
at www.darkhorseadmissions.com
please consider joining our patreons
tomorrow august
29th
at 11 a.m pacific is our private to our
q a at my patreon we have a lot of fun
with those they're small enough that
we're able to pay attention to the chat
and interact with it as it happens
uh you can go to
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
to buy some things and please consider
joining me at natural selections that's
naturalselections.substant.com
my
my post this week was about friendship
and i will continue next week talking
about other ways to
for humans to make meaning in the world
we have two sponsors today so without
further ado let's embark on those zach
all right today's sponsors are vevo
barefoot and omax cryofreeze
you will barefoot make shoes for feet
that sounds unremarkable until you
realize that most shoes are not made for
feet they are made for someone's idea of
what feet should look like and do and be
constrained by most shoemakers have no
idea what feet are or what they should
be able to do that's not true for vivo
barefoot we've been wearing vivo
barefoot for a few months now and
honestly we love them they are beyond
comfortable they feel like you're
barefoot in your shoes you get better
tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on they cause no pain at
all because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they're fantastic and it's frankly
ridiculous how fantastic they are
uh the people at vivo barefoot in fact
say they don't make shoes they make
footwear that allows your feet to do
what they were designed to do so your
body can move the way it was designed to
move in our natural
world uh
millions of years of evolution and our
feet are basically perfect bits of kit
in their language humans have evolved to
essentially walk move and run barefoot
but modern shoe-shaped cushioned shoes
have impacted
impacted foot function
and are contributing to a movement
focused health crisis in the process
so these vivo barefoot are designed wide
to provide natural stability thin soles
to enable you to feel more and flexible
to help you build your natural strength
from the ground up and yet they are they
are containing so you're not slopping
around in these at all it's not like
flip-flops um which are not actually as
it turns out very good for your feet i
have recently learned to my chagrin um
but they they really are terrific shoes
uh and
uh there's some research that shows that
foot strength has increases by 60 in a
matter of months just by walking around
in these shoes um i know that when i'm
wearing them i can easily walk for miles
uh without realizing how far i've gone
and um
and they've got a great range of
footwear for both kids and adults and
for every activity from hiking to
training to everyday wear probably not
your shoes for a formal occasion uh but
yo who knows maybe they'll get to those
get to those next so fivo barefoot is a
certified b court pioneering
regenerative business principles their
footwear is produced using sustainably
sourced natural bio and recycled
materials
with the aim to protect the natural
world so you can run wild on it
go to vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get
an exclusive 20 offer all new customers
also get a 100 day free trial so you can
see if you love them as much as we do
that's vevo barefoot v i v
b
dot com slash dark horse we think you're
gonna love them
you forgot the most important part did i
yes they're sold by the pair checked for
chirality before shipping oh yeah true
general
i mean if they weren't you wouldn't want
them and they're probably toasted as
well
they may well be toasted
all right uh next up is omax cryofreeze
but before we talk about omax cryofreeze
let's talk a little bit about pain
pain is awesome
pain is actually what keeps you safe the
fact is pain is an adaptation it is a
necessary feature of your physiology
that tells you that something is amiss
that you're doing some kind of damage or
that you are putting some part of you at
risk but that said not all pain is
useful sometimes you have a chronic pain
that isn't informing you of anything you
don't know
and in those cases it's just nothing
short of annoying and it's nice to be
able to do something about it so omax
cryofreeze is a roll-on that smells
pleasant contains cbd and does i can
tell you from my own situation does seem
to alleviate pain so for example when we
came back from our uh recent vacation
after way too much
driving i had a pain in my shoulder i
tried a little bit of omax cryofreeze
and the pain alleviated which is lovely
don't have to ingest anything
so
what should you do you should go
to omax health and they have a 20 offer
for our listeners 20 off a full bottle
of omax cryofreeze the discount also
applies to anything on their site
so go to
omaxomaxhealth.com and enter the code
darkhorse to get 20
off cryofreeze sitewide
all right
[Music]
nope
so for those just listening we still got
the green there we go uh when i assume
that everyone watching has figured out
that when we've got that green
perimeter around the screen that means
we are reading sponsored ads and
whenever you don't see that green screen
that green perimeter
that means that whatever we're talking
about we're doing so because um not not
because of any financial incentive at
all okay today we're going to talk about
adulthood
um from a number of different
perspectives
we're going to talk about error
correction we're going to talk about
gratitude and forgiveness and a little
bit about
totalitarianism i think
um but we are going to begin by reading
an excerpt chapter from chapter 11 that
is the adulthood chapter of our
forthcoming book a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century there are 13
chapters in this book so we are coming
up
on the end of these excerpts which means
we're also coming up on publication date
which is just two and a half weeks away
at this point september 14th
so we've got two more chapters after
this week and then i don't know maybe
we'll read something from the epilogue
or the afterward the week after
publication but
we shall see
okay without further ado we've got just
three pages from the middle of the
chapter called becoming adults
and those of you actually before i
embark on this those of you who are
familiar with uh my medium presence and
now i've moved basically all of my new
writing over to the natural selections
on substance
may remember a piece that i run on
post-modernism a couple years ago and
for uh for this section of this chapter
of our book we modified that piece
somewhat so that you will you will hear
some similarities if you're familiar if
you are familiar with that piece
types of reality
remember while e coyote whose life's
work was chasing the roadrunner in
looney tunes cartoons
in hot pursuit he often found himself
skidding off the edge of a cliff where
he would hang suspended in air until he
looked down
gravity did not apply until he
recognized that it should
it was funny because it was ludicrous it
was utterly ludicrous and yet too many
modern people seem to imagine that by
changing people's opinions or
perspectives you change underlying
reality
in short they believe that reality
itself is a social construct
we argued earlier that con artists and
the confused often operate on a holy
social plane rather than on an
analytical one
how do you avoid becoming someone who
assesses the world based on social
responses rather than based on analysis
one of those people who are easily
fooled by con artists and the confused
two good strategies are to regularly
engage with the physical world and to
understand the value of close calls
the sad truth is that the more educated
you are today the harder this is to do
our current higher education system is
steeped in a philosophy that doubts our
ability to even perceive the physical
world that philosophy is called
postmodernism
postmodernists have been at the leading
edge of promoting the view that reality
is socially constructed post-modernism
and its ideological child
post-structuralism were once contained
in a small corner of the academy
these ideologies do contain kernels of
truth
they teach us for instance that our
sensory apparatus biases us and that we
are mostly unaware of those biases
they reveal that school factories and
prisons are similar in their use of
power to control populations that was an
analysis done by michelle foucault in
his metaphorical extension of bentham's
panopticon
and critical race theory has at its
foundation the real observation that the
american legal system has had a
particularly difficult time emerging
from its racist past
and
and the full recovery from that past is
not yet on the horizon
these are a few real and valuable
contributions that such ideologies have
contributed to the world
but most modern instantiations of
postmodernism have jumped the shark
sometimes when fringe academic ideas go
rogue they persist longer than they
might but their impact is limited to a
few university departments
not so with postmodernism and its
downstream effects what what happens on
campus has most definitely not stayed on
campus
postmodernism and its adherence have
infiltrated systems far beyond higher ed
from the tech sector to k-12 schools to
the media and are doing considerable
harm
one of the most astounding conclusions
of some post-modernists is that all of
reality is socially constructed they
have taken they've even taken issue with
the conclusions of newton and einstein
on the basis of the privilege of these
scientists is obvious in their equations
and as old white guys their biases
inherently prevented them from knowing
anything real of the world
people of particular phenotypes this
ironically biologically deterministic
and regressive worldview argues can't
possibly have access to truth
how do you come to be this confused
though to believe that all reality is
socially constructed
have little experience in the real world
no carpenter or electrician could
believe that all of reality is socially
constructed no forklift operator or
sailor could
nori would have thought could any
athlete
there are physical ramifications of
physical actions and everyone operating
in the physical world knows this
if you have not thrown or caught many
balls or used hand tools or laid tile or
driven stick shift in short if you have
little or no experience with the effects
of your actions in the physical world
and therefore have not had occasion to
see the reactions they produce
then you will be more prone to believing
in a holy subjective universe in which
every opinion is equally valid every
opinion is not equally valid and some
outcomes don't change just because you
want them to
social outcomes may change if you argue
or throw a fit
physical outcomes will not
everyone no matter how trapped they are
in their body with its particular flaws
and strengths has the opportunity to
experience the world of actions and
reactions in the physical world
not everyone can bike single track but
for those of us who can and do we face
objective reality in the form of roots
hills and gravity
how given your particular body might you
force your mind and body into
confrontation with physical reality
consider this
our eyes do not produce a static image
like a photograph
rather our eyes are tools of our brains
taking note of the world we are fully
embodied our bodies are not
afterthoughts to our brains or
unnecessary to their interpretation of
the world those eyes and those skulls on
those necks atop those torsos and legs
and feet that move it is all part of
perception perception is an action
the more you move therefore within
whatever your particular limits are the
more integrated whole and accurate your
perception of the world is likely to be
movement increases wisdom
so too does exposure to diverse views
experiences and places we need both
freedom of expression and freedom to
explore because both speak to the value
of environments in which outcomes are
uncertain
nature is still available to us let us
spend time in it and in so doing
generate strength and calibrate our
understanding of our own significance
humans are evolved to be anti-fragile we
grow stronger with exposure to
manageable risks with the pushing of
boundaries fostering openness to
serendipity into that which we do not
yet know
this is true for both bones and brains
doing things with non-negotiable
outcomes in the physical world
skateboarding growing vegetables
ascending a peak provides a corrective
to many wrong-headed ideas currently
passing for sophisticated some of these
include all of reality is a social
construct emotional pain is equivalent
to physical pain and life is or can be
made perfectly safe
a graduate school mentor of ours george
estabrook who is primarily a
mathematical ecologist but who also
spent many years of field seasons
working and living with the
practitioners of a traditional
agricultural system in the hills of
portugal wrote this in the introduction
to one of his papers quote
it is remarkable how the persistent
empiricism of human beings struggling to
make their living in nature results in
practices that make ecological sense
even though they may be codified in
ritual or explained in ways that seem
superficial or not compelling
ecologically
indeed local practitioners may have
concepts equally justifiable but very
different from those of academics of
what constitutes a useful explanation
end quote
if we were forced to choose between the
useful explanation given to us by a
villager versus one provided by your
average academic about an object that
the villager depended on for her
sustenance we would surely choose the
villager's explanation
here we reference part of the
introduction that we haven't yet shared
with you guys that costa rican villager
who likely saved our lives by keeping us
out of a rapidly rising river whom we
talked about in the introduction knew
far more about where we were and how to
interpret the signs than we budding
academics did
you can fool a person and they can fool
you but you can't fool a tree or a
tractor a circuit or a surfboard so seek
out physical reality not just social
experience
pursue feedback from the vast universe
that exists beyond other human beings
watch your reactions when the feedback
comes in
the more time you spend putting your
intellect against realities that cannot
be coerced with manipulation or sweet
talk the less likely you are to blame
others for your own errors
that's the excerpt for today yes
it is interesting how
events
preceding a pace
since we completed
the book
seem to
reflect well on many of the things that
we described as generalities in there
there's just so much of the uh modern
circumstance that um is reflective of
exactly
these kinds of um delusions so once
again the first draft was uh submitted
in march of 2020 just as code was
beginning to descend on the planet
right so um i i am
uh inspired to add one thing that is not
contained in that uh that excerpt yeah
this should be a living document um
the
it is ancient that people should
um have the sense
that their desire for something to be
true if they can only put enough will
behind it affects the uh the truth of
what is correct and that obviously isn't
so
um what we are seeing now involves a
sort of second tier now no doubt this
has ancient origins as well but there is
not only the attempt to force reality to
bend to one's desires
but
we are seeing an industrial strength
campaign now to shift the measurement of
what has taken place so that it will
reflect well on the belief that one can
force something to be by willing it to
be yeah
and this is very it's a very dangerous
kind of transition because
um
the problem is in order to get better we
have to see the error of our ways if the
record of what took place is altered so
that it reflects well on the myopia and
blind spots of those who arrogantly
pushed us in the direction of a policy
then
we aren't an ability in a position to um
correct our
trajectory and actually i'm
uh
many things are happening at once
obviously in the world what's taking
place in afghanistan i think reveals the
full depth of
the hubris of this system of governance
right that um
apparently we you're not you're talking
about the system of governance that we
are engaged in or that they were engaged
no no our system of governance led us
obviously into a uh a situation we
fought for almost a generation
and
the
gains whatever they might have been are
reversed within hours or
days that suggests that whatever stories
we were telling ourselves
were
not
grounded in in reality um in this well
at least they weren't stable
or they they needed more work to become
stable well let's put it this way
presumably i mean
the women's and girls lives were were
improved over the last 20 years in
afghanistan
uh and and
that is that is disappearing right but
we were not we were not those of us in
the society that uh
that launched into this campaign were
not told that what we were doing was
temporarily staving off um
an evil that would descend again as soon
as we left right we were led to believe
that we were accomplishing something and
then we were led to believe that it was
stable
and the opposite has turned out to be
true so i have no doubt that it was um
better to exist in
afghanistan uh under our temporary rule
but the point is
there was nothing accomplished it was a
matter of treading water at least if
this is the way um that we left so
in any case
yes certainly given given the way that
we we left that's a disaster and i think
um you know there's there's a general
question here which is to the extent
that something takes control and decides
to
mislead us
into
pleasant fictions about what our power
in the world might be what we might
accomplish what it will cost
all of these things at the point that we
finally get our comeuppance uh it is an
extremely rude awakening and the
question is how much better off would we
be if we had a system that made an
attempt at least to be honest with us in
real time about what the actual costs of
something are what might actually be
accomplished what are the real risks
of doing this well just as
just as compulsory schooling
was in part
explicitly intended in its origins in
germany and to a large part we we
inherited those intentions when
compulsory schooling
took hold in sort of around the turn of
the last century
was to create a populist that was easily
controlled
that you know as as populations grew and
as industrialization and mechanization
grew
it was
valuable to employers to have a a
workforce
that didn't ask too many questions
and
um
i have not heard it argued explicitly
that it is valuable to a government
that is
that proclaims its democratic intentions
in both its founding texts and in its
current politicians
that it is valuable to have a populist
that is under-informed and yet that is
clearly
uh implicit in the policies uh and the
ways that policies are handed down and
the you know the kinds of the kinds of
proclamations like hashtag follow the
science except we're not going to tell
you anything but the conclusions that
unnamed experts behind closed doors have
arrived at that's not that's not
following the science that's following
the authorities and that's not
scientific right and the implication is
that the authorities um
actually have a better vantage point and
that their interests are synonymous
enough with with ours that what they
tell us is at least a good shot at uh
what is liable to be the right direction
and the very frightening problem is that
once you establish this relationship
that experts will decide something you
won't be able to check it or even
understand who they are or what
motivates them but it's supposed to be
in your interest
it will inevitably be captured and what
is fed to you as the truth as seen by
experts will be propaganda and the
problem is that you are endangered by
the very fact that there is
an engine of propaganda empowered to
dress up like experts and tell you what
it thinks yeah um and you know that's
where we are and so yeah it's wearing
the couture of science without being
science it is the co-tour of science it
is cargo cult science uh as feynman yes
would uh would put it and did put it and
the problem is you know yes it's all
well and good to describe it as cargo
called science but the real point is
what is the danger of such a thing and
the danger of such a thing is
proportional to the seriousness of the
matters that are being navigated by this
pseudo-scientific
process and so
you know i don't want to draw the
connection
too closely but i do think
that to the extent that there is
anything positive to be derived from the
afghanistan situation at all
it is
the recognition that the system that was
capable of making errors this big is in
charge of many other things in which you
are not in a position to see it unfold
on your screen and so the question is
all right
that thing
was certainly so radically incompetent
that it could not possibly be entrusted
with anything important right it
obviously and i'm not regarding what
took place in afghanistan as anything
but of the utmost importance but the
point is that was important that was
clearly lives on the line um and you
know the fate of a people on the line
and uh we see how well it played out we
can see you know the hubris unfolding um
in
in graphic terms but the question is
what also looks like that that is not so
visible or so easy to monitor and
you know
many
many things are of great importance at
the moment we are navigating many
uncharted uh waters and
um
i don't see any evidence that there's a
great deal more competence than what was
in charge in afghanistan in charge of
for example
coveted policy um and so you know people
need to think about that it's at least a
question what if the what if the thing
that made this error is also making
errors with respect to covet that are
equally as as terrifying
right and um
yeah that's that's that's exactly the
question i think that's a good segue
actually to um to the next section um
but before we go there i'm realizing
zack that i forgot to bring a book
upstairs from which i want to read later
and i'm not going to tell you what it's
called because i don't want to reveal
that yet but if you could grab for me or
get toby to grab for me it's a small
black book uh sitting on my desk
downstairs
thank you
um
so we were going to talk a little bit
about um the fact that one thing that
adults do is they correct their errors
and they correct their errors to um
to people you know in their own heads
and they learn from them and they
correct um publicly made errors in a
public way
and so uh
i'm not sure exactly how to how to how
to do this i um i don't think that that
we made an error here but you wanted to
make a correction
uh to uh something that we have talked
about yeah i think there's a
necessity to the extent that what we do
and what i think we do well
is we build a model and we show our work
so that you can decide whether or not
that model
is likely to be accurate you can check
how accurate it is over time and you can
decide for yourself how you know is it a
model for your model is it
too far-fetched and you need to build
something out of different stuff but in
any case what's important is that we
update with information
um figuring out what constitutes
information is not always simple but
when something is a change in the
information that we have available it is
important that we
show you that too and so something that
we have
referred to in a number of different
places
is now in question and we want to show
you what it is and we want uh to suggest
what has happened to our model as a
result so
um
this is uh a discussion of a paper that
people who've followed us for a long
time will have heard us talk about in
one of a number of places including our
substance piece from the very end of
july
the piece is a study of argentinian
healthcare workers the first author is
carvajo zac do you want to put it up for
a second i sent you a link to the pdf
okay so there you can see the paper in
question
now this paper reports of an
extraordinary result it actually reports
two studies one is a preliminary pilot
study and the other is a full-fledged
study of 1200 healthcare workers who
were divided into 800 in the treatment
group and something like 400 in the
placebo
group or the group the non-treated group
and
here is what has happened
i became aware on the ivermectin
subreddit that a
researcher a doctor had requested the
data set
for this study and
he said that he had not been given the
data set which is in and of itself a red
flag because it is standard scientific
practice if you publish a paper based on
a data set and somebody says i'd like to
see that data set you send it to them
and the reason for that are a couple
things one it is important for people to
be able to check whether or not you did
the analysis correctly in other words
maybe you took the data correctly but
the analysis was wrong and if somebody
else looks at the raw data they should
be able to reproduce your result or
discover that it wasn't right
and the other thing is it may be
valuable
to
analyze the data in a different way and
see if there's something else there but
in any case the fact that the data was
not supplied was alarming
and i decided to find out so i also
contacted dr carvajal and i asked him
for the data and he was initially
resistant to giving it to me ultimately
a colleague contacted him requested the
data and he agreed to send it and he has
sent us
a large number of materials from the
study but we do not have a data set and
that uh is concerning um
so
what is one to make of this first of all
it has been about a month that we have
this this began to happen just shortly
after we posted our substack articles
yes i think i made my first request for
the data set on august 1st which was
only a couple days after
i made it as immediately upon uh
hearing that the data set had not been
provided to this other
researcher
in any case the uh the data set has not
arrived uh i have a friend data
scientist who had put together a small
team that was ready to analyze the data
when it was provided in order to figure
out whether it was seriously flawed or
possibly fraudulent we don't know
and in any case because the data set was
never provided they were never able to
do that analysis and basically we've
just been in a holding pattern for the
month so in light of that
what do we make of this well one i still
hold out hope that the data set might
arrive
i would give it to the team of data
analysts and we would find out you know
how well the study holds up
but in the absence of that data set i
think we have to
rate the evidentiary value of this study
at zero because we can't even know for
sure that the study took place so i hope
the data set emerges i hope it happens
quickly but until and unless it does i
would say that everybody should treat
this study with the utmost caution and
not invoke it
i don't think it was incumbent on us to
know that the data set wouldn't be
provided i mean that's not how how
scientific work
progresses you assume studies have taken
place and if you have particular
questions you would you request the data
set and check
but
this is uh i think this is where we are
left now i do have one thing so that is
not a correction of what we have said it
is an update on what the sum total of
the evidence is
it does not affect so this was a study
of prophylaxis it does not affect the
meta analyses that have been discussed
on dark horse and elsewhere it was not a
randomized controlled trial so it was
not included for example in the
lowry meta-analysis
it also doesn't affect any analysis of
the effectiveness of ivermectin as a
treatment because it was a study of
prophylaxis and not treatment
so it does uh it has some impact because
it reported a hundred percent success
at preventing
covid in those who were treated it does
have some impact on the question of you
know is there a prophylactic protocol
that would be uh
so highly protective and we have to
assume the answer is no until we see
evidence otherwise the place where i
would correct myself where i do think i
made an error
is that initially when i spoke of this
study i described it as suggesting there
was a
ivermectin protocol that was 100
effective
that was never implied by the study
because the study was a combination of
ivermectin and carrageenan
and so it is impossible to disentangle
uh what part of the effect is
carrageenan and which part of the effect
would have been ivermectin um and so in
any case i uh
i should have made that clear that it
was a combined protocol from the
beginning and now at this point i would
say no weight should be given to the
study at all yeah
no wait should be given to that study um
in lesson until data are forthcoming
let me just
close that off
by sharing this is a
article that i'm not sure we've talked
about on air before um but it is it is
referenced in that sub stack post uh
that we made at the end of july um and i
just um i just want to share a couple of
sentences from the abstract so this is a
system systematic review of what was
understood this is from
mid-2020
to be
the potential efficacy of ivermectin and
so zach if you would share my screen
this is in the journal of antibiotics by
heideri and garibagi ivormectin a
systematic review from antiviral effects
to govern 19 complementary regimen
and
just uh you know it had so it has
antimicrobial antiviral and anti-concept
property cancer properties it is highly
effective against many microorganisms
including some viruses
in this comprehensive systematic review
anti-viral effects of ivermectin are
summarized including in vitro and in
vivo studies over the past 50 years
here's the one sentence i wanted to to
read on air several studies reported
anti-viral effects of ivermectin
on rna viruses such as zika dengue
yellow fever west nile hendra newcastle
venezuelan equine encephalitis
chikungunya semliki forest syndibus
avian influenza a porcine reproductive
and respiratory syndrome human
immunodeficiency virus type 1 and severe
acute respiratory syndrome coronavirus
2.
so just just to remind us that there is
an abundant literature long before uh
govid and continuing now
about this particular drug and its
efficacy against a wide range of human
and other pathogens yes including many
many viruses which many viruses
especially rna viruses right which you
know again just as a a a uh
lifelong bio geek does make me wonder
what's going on in japanese soil i mean
it's possible that there's a very
interesting story with viruses maybe
bacteriophages in that soil i would love
to know
what explains this and maybe it's not an
ecological story but my my guess is
there's something there's something
interesting to be told there and we just
don't know what it is
yeah
okay let's move on sure um i wanted to
talk a little bit about a conversation i
had today
so i went this morning out to a local
farmer's market uh and it was
less pleasant than it's been in weeks
past because as some viewers will know
are the governor of oregon
uh
reinstated or maybe it may even be the
first time that there's been a mandatory
mask and a mandatory mask
a mask mandate for outdoors under most
circumstances as of yesterday friday
august 27th
and um
as we have talked about since the
beginning of these podcasts back in
march 2020 uh until very recently
there's been no evidence that uh serious
cov2 transmits outdoors um there are now
some glimmers that delta variant may
actually be able to but there has been
no evidence of that
uh up and up until recently and um
having to wear masks at a farmer's
market where you're you know spaced
apart and where the space that you're in
is effectively infinite is
an overreach yes um i want to point out
that to the extent that the outdoor
transmission mode may be increasing this
is absolute absolutely something that we
feared and predicted early on and in
fact our position early on was there is
no evidence this is transmitting
outdoors and it has been checked it's
not that there's just an absence of
evidence it does not appear to transmit
outdoors
but
because that renders outdoors safe we
should protect that environment because
it's one of our greatest assets and so
what we recommended was that actually
people upon coming in close contact
outdoors
do things like mask up and the reason
being that we did not want there we did
not want the virus to find a selective
environment in which it could learn this
trick right so the idea was one probably
should exert more caution than is
warranted by the epidemiology at present
in order to prevent evolution of
this change in the virus so i don't know
whether or not
it will turn out that there is now
outdoor transmission but if it is
um frankly we warned you and it's
another case in which we will have seen
something well ahead well if the virus
remains respiratory it will still be
much more difficult
for it to transmit outside and uh
the the increasing levels of behavioral
coercion that are coming down from on
high and in some parts of the world have
been frankly draconian for a very long
time already uh is
is not serving any of us uh and
um
anyway i had i had been at the farmers
market i you know i i did what i've been
doing for instance when i go to the
market from the beginning of this i put
it on right before i enter where i'm
mandated to wear it and i take it off as
soon as i leave and of course in a
farmer's market that border is um
completely artificial um you know it's
like this
this line demarcates where you're now in
farmer's market territory versus the
outside where people are just as much
milling around and interacting and you
know no one is going up to strangers and
and breathing on them um but that's not
something that you do under normal
circumstances either much as the
distinction between the people walking
in a restaurant and sitting at a
restaurant is arbitrary exactly whereas
you know if
if masks are effective
the demarcation between being inside a
store and outside a store is a real
demarcation that's actually a line that
that makes some sense
so
i had um i had bought the
the peaches and peppers and um dilly
salad mix and berries and
and various other deliciousness that i
um i was intending to buy
and return them to the car and then got
a coffee at a local coffee shop and was
and made a point of sitting on a bench
um on a bench that was empty outside of
this coffee shop at one end of it such
that there was another end and in this
era
um of course uh it
you don't tend to get approached by
strangers who ask if they can sit near
you because um
because people are scared uh and it's uh
you just never know who who or what the
person that you might be sitting next to
um is or believes or might be caring as
a pathogen right um so this this woman
um
totally different um person from the
women i interacted with in a different
spot several weeks ago um who might
talked about on air um but of similar
age probably you know a few years older
than than us um
brett and
uh with grown children but young young
adult children
i don't know this all at first of course
she approached me she's carrying a
couple bags she's got a nice poodle with
her um and um she asks if she can put
the bags down on the bench first and i
of course and then um after a little
while she asks if she if she can sit
down she says she's agreed to meet
someone from craigslist
that she's selling the contents of the
bags to here
and um
and we start talking
and
um and
well actually before she she asked if
she can sit down i said of course
but i'm not i'm not wearing a mask um
you know that that's gonna have to be
okay with you uh she's she says of
course it's outside so i thought good
um she's i think what she said was of
course we're outside after all
um and we then start talking about how
much more difficult this is going to get
as the weather turns and in the pacific
northwest the summers are perfect when
when the smoke doesn't make it
impossible to breathe
uh and
from the fires but the
middle fall through early spring are
pretty dreary and cool and they never
get they usually don't get bitterly cold
but
uh very wet and um you're not going to
be sitting outside
uh you know a coffee shop on a day in on
most days in november it would be too
wet and cold for it um although there
are usually moments in every day when
you could do that
um and we started talking about how
we're we're all going to need to be good
to one another
and to not look at one another with
distrust or anger to not dehumanize one
another and she says that it will
require creativity on all of our parts
and and patience
and she says at some point in here that
uh that she's a a christian and that she
goes to she's a she's a christian enough
and a lot of people claim the mantle of
christianity um but she's a christian
enough that she actually goes to bible
study every week and um and that her
children now grown actually did
admissions when they were in high school
and um i you know i tell her that i'm
not a christian that my you know my
lineage is is christian but um that i am
not but that uh the the teachings in the
new testament are ones that we might all
do well to to abide by
and
some of the i just wanted to share some
of some of the things
that that she shared um
one of the people in her family i'm
gonna i'm gonna leave this a little bit
vague um i did ask her if i could talk
about about our conversation on air and
um she didn't she didn't know of us um
and she said yes
um
one of one of her relatives has an
office in downtown portland um there was
a shooting outside of it last week
sometimes you can't see outside of his
windows because of the literal dumpster
fires so this is still happening um
there is now you know cosplay on both
sides uh in which
uh you have sort of staged extremists um
bringing themselves together to have
fights that look um
look
look staged so the uh the gunfire
outside the office was the the uh
confrontation between the proud boys and
antifa it was it was and um you know of
course these these occasional
altercations
um that have happened between the proud
boys and antifa are the moments that the
proud boys show up whereas antifa has
been present much more consistently um i
would say that there are people um
effectively larping on both sides but
that antifa is are are the people with
the persistent presence
uh in in portland well if i can add one
thing um
these
look uh for one thing they are reported
in a very distorted way um but if you
look at what actually takes place these
are effectively rumbles
that somebody has announced that they're
going to have a demonstration and
someone else decides that they're going
to protect the city from it and
uh
what you have is these pre-announced
rumbles and the amazing thing is that
despite the fact that these rumbles are
violent up through uh
a gun battle in this case um
the police effectively are staying out
of it and leaving portland uh ungoverned
in some ways and it is an absolutely
shocking abdication of responsibility on
the part of our municipal authorities
but in any case yeah no i mean i think i
think that's exactly right and um
you know we talked about
the lack she she and i this woman and i
talked about the
the lack of leadership um and
and
you know why
why aren't the police stepping in at
this point well in part because
uh the police were roundly pilloried for
so many months last year and continued
to be by by many people
who write things like all cops or
bastards and who and things like kill a
pig on on graffiti in downtown portland
and elsewhere
and you know many many good cops are
leaving are retiring
and um this woman has many police in her
uh
among her friends and family as well and
and told of some stories of these you
know these just these good compassionate
honest honorable law enforcement
officers both men and women
who are being attacked for trying to do
their jobs
uh of course at some point at the point
that you have basically rumbles that are
announced in advance between two
opposing sects you know it's uh
it's it's you know it's it's not the
crips and the bloods but it might as
well be
um
the police are gonna say you know what
we're out and where does that leave the
the business owners and the people with
offices who are exactly in the places
where the rumbles are taking place well
it's left you know it's left our
downtown
a complete mess it's a it's a complete
mess well and it's going to become a
disaster as people discover that the
police are not showing up i don't know i
don't think we know to what extent the
decision not to show up is the police
and to what extent you know certainly uh
our mayor seems to proclaim himself
clever for
a strategy that involves staying out of
these things which of course is putting
all the rest of the citizens of portland
in jeopardy
but i don't think we know why these
decisions are being made but what we can
say is that predictably enough if you
keep the police out of things people
will discover all of the things that
they shouldn't be doing and weren't
doing because police were enforcing the
law and so we're headed somewhere very
very dark this last week there were
literally people driving down the
405 the wrong way one of the one of the
major highways through through portland
yep it was uh
filmed apparently there's a group of
people that routinely commandeers
streets and bridges in portland and uh
uses them for their own sporting
purposes you know it's obviously a
completely unsustainable approach and to
the extent that portland is still mostly
hospitable it's oh it's a legacy kind of
stability from when the law was enforced
and you know at some level somebody's
got to wake up yeah no this is
the leaders have long since lost the
plot it would appear um but
the populace
is not as quiet and unaware as as
as we would be told right that those of
us who are seeing things and saying
things
are actually uh much more abundant than
i think it would appear and this is why
this is why i wanted to and i have a few
more things to to say about this
conversation that i had with this
this lovely woman um who you know who
also you know she's in portland she you
know she she says i'm a liberal i've got
you know my she she reports to me that
she's her best friend from high school
lives in another town in oregon that is
um very red and that her friend and her
disagree greatly over politics but that
she loves her dearly and she always will
and that they they can still talk with
compassion and love in their hearts
about their children and about their
futures and about how to make meaning in
the world and how to do good in the
world and the fact that they vote
differently uh doesn't change that uh
and so i would just i would return at
some level to a reminder that you know
you have been saying for for years now
that left right liberal conservative the
vast majority of us share values
and to some degree the biggest thing
that we disagree on actually is what we
think should be done like how to how to
achieve those values and of course right
now things are so fraught but you know
frankly they have been for years now and
so who is served by keeping us at fever
pitch who is served by keeping us at
each other's throats not us definitely
not the people who are at each other's
throats
so this this woman who i spoke with
again on this you know beautiful day a
block from a farmer's market in front of
a coffee shop with lots of people
walking by her poodle attracting
attention because he's a handsome dog
she says her son who lives in northeast
portland had his car broken into which
has never happened before and we got it
fixed and then he parked it in the
parking garage in downtown portland and
it was broken into again and you know
this
you know these sorts of things didn't
used to happen with regularity in
portland and they are happening
increasingly and of course this is
anecdote but this is all from this is
all from one conversation
um so you know why is this kind of
anarchic behavior on the rise aside from
the fact that we have vilified the
police exactly the people
who
society has enjoined to help keep us
safe we have basically said we have no
use for you and
you know and we've
as a society have made them
try to make them irrelevant and of
course in so doing have made them more
relevant than ever
but people are scared and underemployed
and without agency having had it taken
away from them you know you must do this
when you do that you must you know you
must
there's so many things we've been only
we're being told we must do and other
things we're being told we're not
allowed to do and the more of those
people acquiesce to the more they will
continue to acquiesce to
in the future
um
i would i guess add just a couple more
things that she said um she said to me
um
that she used to say to her children
before they were grown out of the house
this again she's a she's a liberal
christian woman um who really who does
bible study on the regular so really
actually christian
if there's anything more complex than a
human being it's a relationship between
human beings
which reminded me very much in fact i
told her at that point i said you know
my husband i have this book coming out
and it's not a christian book it's an
evolutionary biology book but that
reminds me so much of what of of what
our approach is
and we talked she and i about the value
of getting out of your own bubble
and you know as i've said on this on
this podcast many times before
so many people who would claim that
america is terrible haven't been
anywhere else or if they've if they have
traveled they've gone and they've gone
within their with their bubble around
them to some disney disney fight version
or a place where they can continue to
carry their
their cultural privilege frankly
and um being able to actually travel and
actually experience how people live that
aren't living the same way you are gives
a perspective that can't be attained any
other way
and i offered knowing at this point that
this was a woman um
a christian but i didn't yet know that
her children had been on missionary
trips i invoked missionary trips i said
you know for me it was international
travel um as a as a field scientist um
in in part that really allowed me to to
to see this to know this reality that um
that i live a life that is more
privileged and differently you know
different than so many other people that
you can't just read about
i said i suspect that that's actually
one of the um
one of the values and virtues of
missionary trips as well and uh you know
i used to occasionally run into
missionary groups when i was flying to
madagascar or to panama and i didn't
i didn't like that they were there right
i felt it felt coercive and
intrusive and
um you know not not okay
but i also never interacted with any of
those people and found them hostile or
mean or disingenuous
um so one thing that i've come to
understand about what i think the point
of missionary trips is and what i said
to her i sort of posit it to her as a
kind of hypothesis although i don't
think i said it that way was
that they're actually as much about
inner growth as about spreading the word
of of jesus that they're about exposing
the young people to other ways of being
so that they can appreciate what they
have and so they can know how many
different ways there are to be human in
the world and how at base the the things
that unify us that unite us are far
greater than the things that divide us
that we are much more similar than we
are different
and um she said absolutely and her
children actually did do missionary
trips and in fact one of the places they
did missionary trips to was the
tenderloin district in san francisco i
didn't know that was a thing
the tenderloin is
not a pleasant place to be at this point
i don't think for anyone even if you
live there um the last time we were
there we sort of stumbled into it a
couple of years ago and we were
wandering around san francisco and it
was it was terrible completely awful
yeah we were i mean it's an experience
you you almost never have in any major
american city we were uh
shouted at i can't remember what the
content was but simply walking along the
street we were actually just simply
shouted at which you know
i can't remember the last time that
happened yeah i thought i thought spit
out as well although i'm not sure um and
you know they were by you know obvious
you know people who are not doing well
you know heroin addicts and and
prostitutes and um you know people who
who are on the streets and not able to
get off the streets
um and so her children did these
missionary trips to the tenderloin and
um and then also um
one of them one or more of them went to
um
a private liberal arts college and that
that also felt very far afield from
their experience
uh and that when with their at their
college they had been surrounded by what
she called sort of the country club kids
which is not who their kids were and of
course in the tenderloin um they were
surrounded by people who were you know
beyond down on their luck which is also
not her children's experience and what
she said to me was i want my children to
be equally capable of finding the
humanity in people in the country club
and in the tenderloin
and i mean that
that's it really like we we
that's what we need to be doing is to
find be finding our common humanity and
to be discussing
with um
with a constant undercurrent of of
recognition that you're talking to
another human being and that you may
disagree with them about all manner of
things but that they are just as worthy
of of respect and care as as you are
and that that seems to me to be
increasingly missing from our discourse
um and we can either talk about that now
or um
the last thing that i explicitly or two
more things but the next thing that i
want to do is uh read a little excerpt
from the book that i happened to be
reading when she walked up to me
well
one thing i would say is you know i
think the assumption needs to be that
interacting with another person no
matter who they are that they are
equally deserving of
of respect as you are or as anyone else
is the problem is that we are running up
against so much in which people have
effectively sold out their obligation to
uh us as fellow humans and yeah that is
not deserving of
respect and so
we are weirdly divided i think your
point from earlier uh a few minutes ago
was exactly accurate
even though we agree overwhelmingly on
what world we want to live in for the
most part
we have been falsely polarized into
camps that cannot see the humanity in
the other and that is not for our
benefit that is um yes
um
let's put it this way were those of us
who agree on
what sort of society we want to live in
but maybe disagree about how close we
are to it or what might lead us in the
right direction we would be an
absolutely unstoppable majority in a
democracy so we must not be united we
must be we must be forced not to be able
to see each other in order not to be so
powerful just to be i mean i think i
think you were clear but if if you tuned
out and tuned back in it might it might
have sounded like you were saying it's
not possible that we're united and what
you what you are saying is that um those
who would control us cannot allow for us
to know that we are united
right so uh we haven't talked about it
in some time but the hidden tribes
report for example describes what it
calls the exhausted middle which is this
very large majority that are basically
in agreement that aren't extreme on
questions of religion they're not
extreme on questions of abortion on
questions of uh gun rights and gun
control they overwhelmingly agree on the
basics
and so the point is well why is there no
party that speaks to that middle ground
and the answer is because there can't be
if there was then the things that are
that do have their interest represented
in our
captured governance structure would lose
their power so
in some sense we need to um
or maybe maybe the best thing is you
know i used to say that the uh
the npr listener regards the fox news
viewer as insane and the fox news viewer
regards the new york times reader npr
listener uh as if they've lost their
mind and they're both right
you know the point is
each side has something that it sees
with clarity and then its blind spot
contains all sorts of nonsense and the
problem is um you have to get over the
sense that that person you know who
tunes into that channel that you can't
stand
um is simply you know if you think that
their
worldview has no value in it that they
haven't seen anything right that
actually you could take their worldview
and take the inverse of it and that
would be correct if that's the quality
of your thinking then you can't get out
of this if you realize that actually
um
you know the right for example is
correct about the hazard of unintended
consequences of new policies and the
right is incorrect for example about the
hazard that um industrial civilization
poses to the planet right if you can
that is that they under undervalue the
hazard
right they tend to they tend to think
things are better than they are
ecologically that things there's a
cornucopianism right um
then you know if you can see both of
those things
then there's somewhere to go if you're
if you can only see
uh half the equation then the point is
okay yes then you will forever be uh
unable to recognize what
the vast
amount that we
agree on before we ever get to the part
that we really disagree on yeah and you
know i mean the final chapter of our
book really talks about the society-wide
stuff and the political divisions so
we'll be talking a lot more about this
in a couple of weeks as well
but um
you know it right versus left
conservative versus liberal
you know there are various definitions
out there of course and um one of the
things that we
that we heard a lot after evergreen
uh was well see you're not that you're
not really liberal because look at all
the people on the right who who you
agree with uh to which our point was
actually that's a post-modern
perspective and we're not on the left
because of our social group or on the
left because of um our overwhelming uh
belief in in what policies will help us
get to the world that uh we all want to
live in and we do believe that the vast
majority of us want to live in the same
kind of world but we disagree about how
to get there and i guess um i would say
you know maybe a better response even is
if if left
if broadly speaking and there will be of
course many people who will disagree
with these categorizations but if the
left is about leaving the past behind
and moving forward into a future that we
haven't yet seen and if the right is
about uh returning to a past uh that is
imagined to be rosy and perfect and um
and
and um not making the mistakes of of um
progress that goes too fast and of
course that's that's imperfect at best
um there's you know given that uh you
know business tends to be um you know
voting on the right and business is
about you know
productivity and growth and such it's
imperfect um well if if you do though
frame it as basically are you interested
in a past that you believe was excellent
and could be returned to or a future
that you believe could be better
how about both like don't we need both
of course we need both we need um we
need neither one in isolation we need to
retain those aspects of the past that
have been functional and remain
functional and about which we know
little enough yet to mess with without
risking
collapsing whole systems and we need to
be able to move forward in a way that is
um careful but also creative and
innovative and unforeseen and yes we
will make mistakes but uh we also have a
chance of making the world even better
for our descendants well you need to
have the tension and you need not to
depend on
the pendulum mechanism the pendulum
mechanism is in some sense
uh
an unacceptable
an acceptably crude feedback mechanism
right you know
in other words if you think about the
way
complex systems complex adaptive systems
that actually maintain stasis work
you know your temperature isn't wildly
fluctuating you know you don't
get a fever right and then the system
that you know uh then
sheds heat you know kicks into high gear
and you become so cold you can't
function right it's not like that the
point is it's
it's a very narrow modulation that keeps
you so close to the optimal temperature
or at least the important parts of you
so close to the optimal temperature that
you function very well and the point is
our system
is sort of reactionary in both
directions right our system lets the
progressives run wild they create all
sorts of unintended consequences which
creates a you know a distaste for
progressivism which then results in a
reactionary uh
overcompensation that's not a good way
of navigating
you know an enlightened more adult way
of navigating is to recognize that
actually
anybody who thinks their side of the
right left divide is correct is wrong
right it is the tension between them
that allows you to navigate in some
useful way and so that's sort of like
you know
entry into the adult conversation is do
you recognize that it's a tension
between the instinct toward
progressivism and the instinct to
preserve that which functions that
actually makes the system work and get
better yeah and then from there you can
navigate but you know as you were
mentioning earlier this week
we've lost
the instinct
we've lost even the belief in the loyal
opposition both sides are so busy
painting the other as
detestable and you know beneath contempt
and unworthy of
of
dignity or whatever it is
that
um you know
we are watching some kind of a psychosis
right we're watching people who have
lost
basic track of what it is that actually
made the system work in the first place
and somehow we're gonna have to regain
control of it that's right
so the book that i was reading
uh when when this woman approached me we
had this conversation
uh was ellie b cells night
and it is uh for those unfamiliar with
it uh his
his autobiographical tale of having gone
from being a
i think he's 15
um year old
living jewish boy living with his family
in czechoslovakia
and then
being dragged into auschwitz and losing
most of his family
but before
while their world still looked somewhat
intact
um
just a little excerpt from this
spring 1944
splendid news from the russian front
there could no longer be any doubt
germany would be defeated it was only a
matter of time months or weeks perhaps
the trees were in bloom it was a year
like so many others with its spring its
engagements its weddings and its births
the people were saying the red army is
advancing with great giant strides
hitler will not be able to harm us even
if he wants to
yes he even we even doubted his resolve
to exterminate us
annihilate an entire people wipe out a
population dispersed throughout so many
nations so many millions of people by
what means in the middle of the 20th
century
and thus my elders concerned themselves
with all manner of things
strategy diplomacy politics and zionism
but not with their own fate
even moisha the beatle had fallen silent
he was weary of talking he would drift
through synagogue or through the streets
hunched over eyes cast down avoiding
people's gaze
he was someone who had seen some of the
truth of what the nazis were up to and
could not convince his fellow villagers
in those days it was still possible to
buy immigration certificates to
palestine i had asked my father to sell
everything to liquidate everything and
to leave
i am too old my son he answered too old
to start a new life too old to start
from scratch and some distant land
budapest radio announced that the
fascist party had seized power
the regent miklos horthy was forced to
ask a leader of the pro-nazi nila's
party to form a new government
yet we were still not worried
of course we had heard of the fascist
but it was only abstract it meant
nothing more to us than a change of
the next day brought really disquieting
news
german troops had penetrated hungarian
territory with the government's approval
finally people began to worry in earnest
one of my friends moisheheim berkowitz
returned from the capital for passover
and told us the jews of budapest live in
an atmosphere of fear and terror
anti-semitic acts take place every day
in the streets on the trains the
fascists attack jewish stores synagogues
the situation is becoming very serious
the news spread through sikkat like
wildfire soon that was all people talked
about
but not for long
optimism soon revived the germans will
not come this far they will stay in
budapest for strategic reasons for
political reasons
in less than three days german army
vehicles made their appearance on our
streets
one more one more paragraph
anguish
german soldiers with their steel helmets
and their death side emblem still our
first impressions of the germans were
rather reassuring
the officers were billeted in private
homes even in jewish homes their
attitude towards their hosts was distant
but polite
they never demanded the impossible made
no offensive remarks and sometimes even
smiled the lady of the house
a german officer lodged in the khan's
house across the street from us we were
told he was a charming man calm likable
and polite
three days after he moved in he bought
mrs khan a box of chocolates
the optimists were jubilant well what
did we tell you you wouldn't believe us
there they are your germans what do you
say now where is their famous cruelty
the germans were already in our town
the fascists were already in power the
verdict was already out
and the jews of sight were still smiling
we never see it when it happens
yeah i have to say that's
uh
makes me very angry to hear
actually um tell what what is that well
um
i had not shared that with you yeah
i think there's something about it
because
you know
there are these photographs that emerged
some years ago lost photographs of
nazis
men and women
outside
of i think auschwitz
enjoying blueberries or something right
there's something about
the recognition of
how much
they understood and yet were willing to
behave
as they did that is
it's more chilling
it places the crime in an even more
chilling context and hearing about you
know what is obviously the immediately
before times
um
is very frightening now of course the
people themselves the targets the people
who will largely be annihilated the man
writing this book ellie visel obviously
survived most of his family did not
could not
convince themselves that what they were
seeing the intimations they were getting
what they were hearing was real
i think i think the problem and you know
we we keep encountering this in
different places uh eric years ago
pointed me to this uh this costler piece
um the screamer
which
makes this point about the difficulty of
seeing these things as they actually
occurred rather than as history
writes them i mean the idea that you
know world war ii was fought without
uh the full awareness of the population
about what they were in fact fighting
about they knew who they were fighting
but um
you know
uh certainly the
certainly the american uh
men who were fighting in the european
theater had no idea
well there's a question about who had no
idea and the the point of the screamers
is that many people had every reason to
know and yeah somehow managed to
convince themselves that it wasn't
happening right um but there is also the
fact that we tend to synonymize the
holocaust and world war ii and in fact
the holocaust was revealed by the
success in
in the war you know what had taken place
is revealed later and of course for all
of those of us too young to have been
alive at that point it sort of all gets
written as the history of the moment
rather than the history of the
revelation
right i mean
that's that's critical actually there's
like a we need a
history that takes into account theory
of mind like the people who you're
reading about who lived concurrently
with things but they didn't know or they
could have known but they didn't know
they were they had a cognitive
dissonance
or they really didn't know and yet they
were still willing to fight like all of
these things were realities for people
and
you know having having it be in history
means that it's very hard for most of us
to do the additional level of theory of
mind of like okay i'm sorry you know god
doesn't play dice but maybe you do is
that what's going on yes
okay
um
it's it's very hard for us to know um to
to recognize
what what people's lives are actually
like which is part of why these
first-person accounts um from from
someone as extraordinary as elie bisell
are are so critical to to
to be reflected and of course he's
reflecting after he has survived and
most of his family hasn't so you know
he's writing um in in retrospect
um but to be remembering that there were
indication indications and that it was
still so desirable to just to enjoy
spring right to to enjoy the peaches and
the engagements and you know
summer but you know to to to
to be human with one another even as
there may be people who are actively
working to take that humanity away
well there's definitely an aspect
of
it's later than you think
and that's the problem is that
to have an accurate reaction before the
germans descend in that piece in that
segment that you read
before they descended was the right time
to
react
to prepare to flee or to figure out how
to fight and what
the excerpt you read
reports is essentially a rationalization
process
about why it won't be all that bad and
then it you know there's a reassuring
oh here is all the evidence that it
isn't that bad and the point is of
course it was exactly that bad and far
worse
but
the question really
the obvious question is how to
extrapolate from this right it could
always be later than you think and then
the point is you should always be in a
state of preparing for
it being
exactly that bad and far worse which of
course wouldn't make any sense because
it isn't always that bad but the
question is where are you in history and
one of the things i've been wrestling
with in in the present
is
of course we have been divided into two
camps about everything right and the
camps aren't you know it's
sometimes you fall in different
uh on different sides based on different
divisions but nonetheless there is a a
kind of
um
[Music]
kovitt isn't that serious
this is an excuse for authoritarianism
right that's like a camp
right and then there's a covet is very
serious and this is about public health
you dummies right and the point is
neither of these things are right well
those those are two camps that have
those are categories those are sets that
are not empty people belong people many
believe most people most people but it's
but those two things do not a solution a
complete solution set me right exactly
and and that's what i'm getting at is
covet is extremely frightening and the
fact that it probably has an at least
somewhat non-natural origin makes it
even more frightening because it means
it's harder to predict what it's going
to do
right
well and add to that that we still
aren't
fully allowed to talk about what that
means about policy with regard to future
research and gain of function research
and right and how did this come together
how will such a thing be avoided in the
future if we can't talk about origins
right and
to the extent that there appears to be a
very credible
argument that gain of function research
taking place in wuhan was the result of
americans circumventing their own legal
ban on gain of function research and
funneling
resources to wuhan in order to get the
work done how is it possible that one of
the people in charge of our pandemic
response is also one of the people
responsible for
you know whether or not this is where
the virus came from one of the people
responsible for um circumventing that
ban there's no way
anthony fauci should be in charge of our
pandemic response no matter what so just
to that end let me say um i recommend
listening to josh rogan on barry weiss's
honestly podcast there's a two-part um
discussion of uh of
basically how china's role in um
in
changing the narrative that we are all
engaged in and and they talk about this
and it's it's it's a remarkable set of
conversations i'm not quite done with
the second one but i'm looking forward
to listening to it myself
i will say
we have to ask the question to what
extent are the narratives that we are
battling over
being fed to us by something that does
not have our navigating the pandemic
well um
you know at its core and doesn't mean
that we are being fed narratives from
somewhere else but it's at least a
possibility and that would explain in
part why we are managing it so badly if
that were
uh
shifting our
our view and our approach
narrative control is uh um incredibly
powerful kind of control because it
doesn't require the infrastructure it
doesn't require physical movement of
things in this in this day and age right
um yeah and yes the opportunity for it
obviously exists and so what are the
chances that opportunity is not being
utilized right or has been completely
neutralized is pretty low chance but in
any case what i would say is
the two camps
are clearly both wrong
right those two camps uh
kovid is not a real thing and covet is
not serious
it's not serious this is an excuse for
authoritarianism and the other camp
being being coveted is extremely serious
and the authoritarianism isn't
authoritarianism it's public health okay
so those two camps are both wrong
they're both wrong right
it is quite clear that covet is a very
dangerous disease i mean it's really
it's like physiologically diabolical
right what it does to the body
long covered all of these things it is
not to be trifled with yeah the ground
glass opacities in the lungs alone yeah
right
on the other hand
it does seem to be the um
excuse for an awful lot of
authoritarianism that makes no sense
right
and in in one way actually i think
there's a litmus test
right that we can use to detect that
there is something about this that is
just absolutely not public health and
incoherent right
not only is it the case
that there's nothing about the current
policy even if everybody were to comply
completely that actually brings stars
kovi to under control right can't do
that even in principle
um
but there's also
this issue i probably should have
prepared with a
diminishing returns graph but
the
[Music]
the fact is diminishing returns is a
feature of any complex system in which
there is an objective right there are
complex systems that have no objective
uh weather is a complex system in which
there's no objective and so you can't
say that they're diminishing returns in
in the case of weather because um
because there's no there's no there's no
such thing as a return yeah so you want
to show this
zach you can show my screen so this is
actually a figure from the final chapter
of our book
um so this is going to describe it for
people just listening sure this is a
simplified diminishing returns curve and
basically if you imagine
so
the x-axis is investment the y-axis is
return
there is a
a shallow early phase that then curves
up and becomes a steep
effectively a cliff face
and then
in which your investment is low relative
to the returns that you get for it right
right the early the early stages i'm
trying to figure out what it is like
what am i learning how to skateboard or
whatever it is and it's tough at first
and then you hit some point like oh i'm
getting this i'm getting this i'm
getting this and then what happens at
the inflection point in the curve you um
you get the emergence of a plateau where
larger and larger investments and that
smaller and smaller gains and it's not i
mean it's not
in some cases it will be but um we
didn't mean for it to be drawn exactly
as a plateau yeah there's a little bit
of it's an asteroid
it's an asymptote there's still there's
still returns on investment but they get
less and less anyway the point is the
reason that you get a diminishing
returns curve in a complex system in
which there's an objective is that you
have a hierarchy of interventions right
you've got some stuff that's actually
no-brainers that work really well and
you do those things first obviously
because why wouldn't you and the point
is the more of those things you've
already done the more of the low-hanging
fruit you've
uh you've found the more you're forced
to do things that yes work but at some
very large cost and so anyway you get
this pattern reliably because a
reasonable
a reasonable person or system attempting
to solve a problem will go after the low
hanging fruit first we'll find it and
we'll be left with smaller and smaller
interventions that are more and more
expensive eventually getting to a point
of near pointlessness
but in any case the point is
our response to covid
does not show an indication that we have
gone after the low-hanging fruit
at all
right it's completely insane with
respect to the low-hanging fruit that we
have left on the table and not invoked
and this is left for instance well for
instance um the most obvious one and the
thing that i would suggest that we use
as a litmus test
is the question hold on a second hey z
could i get my screen back thank you is
the question of
uh vitamin d there it is now the vitamin
d question is not simple it's not a
simple matter of take vitamin d avoid
covid right you can take vitamin d and
still get covid but it is a matter of
the evidence
strongly suggests that vitamin d
deficiency makes you much more
vulnerable to cova this is completely
unambiguous
and
that what's more that people who live
far from the equator as many of us do
are very likely to be vitamin d
deficient during the winter months why
because vitamin d is naturally produced
on the skin in response to sunlight and
so what that means is that vitamin d
deficiency which might not be inherent
to humans is very common amongst modern
humans because of the way we live
because we spend a lot of time indoors
because many of us live in cold climates
where climate control allows us to
continue but we are then
chronically underexposed to sunlight
that would produce vitamin d and
therefore vitamin d supplementation has
tremendous value in terms of fending off
covid for people who are likely to
experience deficiencies what's more
vitamin d is inexpensive vitamin d is
readily available and vitamin d not only
does it not have serious downsides but
if you take reasonable amounts of
vitamin d you are very likely to fend
off other diseases because vitamin d
deficiency makes you uh is basically
immunosuppressive just uh one one
comment there is the possibility of
overdosing yes because it's fat soluble
because it's fat soluble and not water
soluble it is possible to take too much
so be mindful but the point is
many of us have vitamin d deficiencies
in the winter they have impacts on our
health that are negative those
deficiencies do there's probably little
or no advantage of having more than
enough vitamin d but getting to the
point that you do not have a deficit of
it makes a great deal of sense and yet
we are somehow still not
widely recommending vitamin d to
everybody who's likely to have that
deficiency in the winter in spite of the
fact that we have a raging pandemic
and we could
reduce the number of cases substantially
by simply making that one intervention
yeah so now and there's uh sorry to know
for just a second i was just this uh one
of my posts on natural selections i was
specifically talking about vitamin d
this is the hospital's post
vitamin uh you don't have to show this
vitamin d you can whatever
vitamin d has been identified and this
is just a short list as having effects
beneficial to the individual with regard
to immunity autoimmunity cardiovascular
disease cancer fertility pregnancy and
dementia among other things and here i
linked to a 2013 review article
vitamin d effects on musculoskeletal
health immunity et cetera et cetera a
review of recent evidence so you know
it's just it's it's
one of these sort of you know wonder
wonder molecules at some level um that
yes you can overdo it but it's very much
more likely that you have effectively
underdone it with regard to where you
live you can overdo it and above a level
where you have adequate amounts of
vitamin d it probably does you very
little good but the point is many of the
cases of covid that people get are
downstream of deficiencies where they
wouldn't have gotten the case or would
have been much better off if they had
had vitamin d so the question is how on
earth is this not our first
recommendation to people that you if you
have any danger of a vitamin d
deficiency that you do something about
it that includes
making vitamin d while the sun shines by
going outside and exposing yourself to
sunlight and as that becomes less and
less
useful as an intervention supplementing
with biologically available vitamin d
that would
compensate for a deficiency so i would
say that's a litmus test why is it a
litmus test because it's the lowest
hanging fruit so remind us again that
was just i i i followed that circle but
uh we're now talking about low hanging
fruit with regard to you know why is the
pandemic response not encourage people
to do the obvious inexpensive clearly
useful things such as go outside be
active supplement supplement with
vitamin d if there's any reason to
suspect that you are deficient in it
those are some low hanging fruit
recommendations public health
recommendations that enrich no one right
but contribute greatly to public health
right there is
no good reason not to address the
question of vitamin d deficiency first
it's the lowest hanging fruit it should
have been our first our first
intervention and the fact that we didn't
do it is evidence of one of two things
it is either evidence of
absolutely jaw-dropping levels of
incompetence
which is possible or that something else
is driving our policy that isn't really
obsessed with preventing covid um and we
don't know which it is but i mean let's
say it's the better of them it's
jaw-dropping incompetence well that's
the kind of incompetence that can be
fixed at any moment you know all you
know any one of these organizations can
start saying on top of everything else
and maybe most of what we're telling you
is garbage but you really ought to
consider vitamin d you're vitamin
because this is just something you can
add at any moment it's not like well
that ship has sailed we can't start
recommending vitamin d now like no it's
not like that so i mean but what happens
at the cdc when somebody who didn't get
the memo shows up at the meeting and is
like hey i've got a great idea check out
how effective vitamin d is for people
who are deficient this is a a
spectacular intervention it really
prevents a lot of cases of cove let's
just recommend it because at least we
can all agree on that right and then
what happens what kind of crickets like
how does that know vitamin d deficient
crickets
maybe
yes uh so in any case uh
when the lowest hanging fruit on the
tree has not been picked something is up
that at least amounts to jaw-dropping
incompetence yeah that's that's the
the shallow end
okay so um
at the end of most of the chapters in
this book we have something called the
corrective lens
in which we provide you know actionable
suggestions um that follow from some of
the analysis and stories that we've
provided in the rest of the chapter this
one the corrective lens items on this
chapter are long i was considering
reading all of them but i think i won't
read all of them
but there are a couple that are
particularly salient i think given the
conversation we just had
the first one is
explicitly aimed to be an adult do this
in part by regularly asking yourself the
questions that we post at the beginning
of the chapter for instance am i taking
responsibility for my own actions am i
being close-minded and by minimizing the
effects of economic markets on your
daily life
become aware of the constant flow of
information telling you what to think
how to feel and how to act do not let it
into your mind do not let it steer you
your internal reward structure needs to
be independent and ungamable that
independence in turn should allow you to
collaborate well with others who are
similarly independent be wary of those
who may well be nice but who are
captured
um
there's a lot there's i think these are
all good we wrote them um
four more
smile at people
the people with whom you live the person
behind the counter the stranger on the
street
put your phone down no really put it
down
define your fights for whom and what you
love rather than against whom and what
you hate
if a mob ever comes for people you know
people whom you consider friends stand
up and say no you're wrong
be honorable and courageous when bullies
move in speak up for what you know to be
true even if it makes you a social
pariah
and finally apropos the discussion of
diminishing returns curse which we don't
have a picture of here but we do in the
final chapter of the book learn to jump
curves
diminishing returns are a factor for
every complex phenomenon so learn to
jump curves put another way consider
learning a new thing rather than being a
perfectionist and trying to get ever
better at whatever you are already
really really good at
we'll speak to this more in the final
chapter
and therefore we'll speak to that more
here in a couple of weeks um
are we there i think we are for the week
all right um
and we thank you for joining us and if
you are here with us live right now uh
stay tuned we will be back uh in as
close to 15 minutes as the tech allows
us
with the q a you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
consider joining one or both of our
patreons tomorrow at my patreon at 11am
pacific on sunday august 29th
is this month's private q a for two
hours
you can find shirts at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
you can email logistical but not uh
questions for the q a logistical
questions darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
um and please consider subscribing to
all four of our channels we've got two
here on youtube brett weinstein's main
channel and the dark horse podcast clips
channel and identically named channels
on odyssey
anything you want to say before
take us out ah i think i said it make
vitamin d while the sun shines make d
while the sun shines and be good to the
ones you love
eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
you